et
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir elie
crever l'éditorialiste rt france bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous franck
louvrier sur ce plateau conseiller
politique de valérie pécresse candidate
les républicains évidemment la
présidentielle 2022 avec nous également
alexis poulain historia liste arte
france également ainsi que fabien lainé
un député modem des landes bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous une
réaction tout d'abord cette visite un là
ça fait quoi cinq heures quasiment que
les deux hommes un venir patiner
emmanuel macron sont en train de
discuter c'est plutôt de bonne augure et
les crevel vous l'observateur de ces
années bon moi j'ai suivi quelques
mèches présidentielle où c'est du temps
de françois mitterrand alors ils
allaient moins en russie mais
non mais non mais là c'est effectivement
l'entretien a commencé à 16h30 donc ça
dure c'est son nom plutôt de bonne
augure parce que sinon il ya peut-être
un début d'accord sur un point il faudra
voir parce que c'est vrai que
l'entretien comme extrêmement long alors
je sais pas si l'entretien est finie et
s'il dit ne me disant voilà il dîne dont
peut-être que la discussion souvent
entre deux chefs d'état continuent
évidemment pendant le dîner mais
peut-être que au niveau international et
au niveau d'ailleurs
intérieure le président macro on va
pouvoir
accrocher avant d'être candidat au
revers de son veston un début de succès
alors les français votent jamais sur une
question internationale mais enfin lui
qui a parfois souffert d'un manque de
stature présidentielle peut être que là
il détient quelque chose franck louvrier
quand vous avez vu ces deux hommes
attablés se toiser avant cette grande
conversation qu'est ce que vous vous
êtes dit vous avez beaucoup d'attentes
vous
rue bat d'abord c'est un rendez vous à
la fois franco français européen et
international bien évidemment l'europe
était très absente de cette situation
diplomatique malheureusement encore une
nouvelle fois la france est arrivé un
peu en retard de cette situation le je
dirais que binôme franco-allemand a été
assez boiteux dans cette histoire chacun
ayant des intérèts un peu différent et
c'est vrai que c'est aussi un enjeu
international pour la simple et bonne
raison c'est qu'on voit que dans ceux
tensions il y à la fois les états unis
qui joue un rôle un petit peu je dirais
qui souffre un peu sur les braises
peut-être aussi parce que leur situation
intérieure les amène à le faire là et
c'est vrai que le président français se
retrouve aussi à jouer un double jeu à
la fois le jeu international mais aussi
le jeu de politique intérieure fabien
lainé vous beaucoup d'attentes pour
cette rencontre parce qu'on nous avait
un petit peu prévu en dombes est
d'ailleurs le kremlin ça ne va pas
vraiment faire bouger les lignes mais le
fait qu'ils essaient ces discussions
nous avait aussi prévenu que ça allait
durer comprendrait le temps c'est plutôt
de bonne augure selon vous
oui il faut être dans un optimisme
prudent ce oui c'est une très bonne
nouvelle que nous reprenions les
discussions avec avec des russes avec la
dga routine tout le monde à emmanuel
macron a tenté de rétablir le contact
avec le président russe et c'est
l'intérêt même de l'europe de la
sécurité du continent européen que ces
discussions sportives art bonne nouvelle
emmanuel macron est prise dans l'union
européenne aujourd'hui pour six mois
ici la libye routine qui a souhaité ses
entretiens avec le punk is honda france
le prix en union européenne en exercice
donc oui je pense qu emmanuel macron
beaucoup consulté ses partenaires on
perd nos partenaires américains
notamment dans le cadre de l'otan il va
pas les mains vides il est mandaté
aujourd'hui mandaté mais assez libre
pour négocier avec le président russe il
puis il ira qui est quand vous le savez
de demain il ira voir deux groupes ce
lié allemande éclot petit dans polonais
à berlin dans deux jours oui que les
modèles à écran et dans un esprit de
discussion voilà les tickets mis de
pression diplomatique qui critiquent
aujourd'hui c'est d'un pays qui menacent
d'envahir un état souverain pour
regarder l'histoire on y reviendra
certainement mais aujourd'hui ce qui
nous intéresse c'est le respect du droit
international et la sécurité de l'europe
à ses frontières et en cela je me
réjouis que l'on puisse parler que le
présent match qu'on puisse parler au
président comptines et puis peut-être
que ça permettra de percer certains
accès que nous avons depuis longtemps
avec nancy se parler franchement ça peut
être un gage de bonne relations à venir
en tout cas c'est en tant que président
français en coq emmanuel macron se
déplace ce soir et pas en tant que
présidente de l'union européenne
officiellement
il a quand même beaucoup
c'est une rencontre
oui oui c'est une rencontre bilatérale
il n'a pas de demande a même si les
présidents du conseil européen il n'est
pas là pour représenter l'europe se dit
d'ailleurs tout le problème de la
diplomatie européenne qui a bien du mal
à exister nathalie oiseaux parlait d'une
suisse molle elle s'en est excusé par la
suite mais voilà un peu l'idée qu'ont
les européens de la stratégie
diplomatique européenne et puis il y a
dans cette volonté de l'admirent poutine
de parler à la france les deux pays qui
compte en europe c'est la france bien
sûr et l'allemagne avec l'intérêt on
n'en a pas encore parlé mais du gaz de
nord stream 2 qui est au coeur de cette
histoire chrétienne puisque les
américains ont intérêt à pousser la
fermeture de nord stream et à imposer le
gaz liquéfié de provenance des états
unis sur le marché européen pour
l'allemagne ainsi que les intérêts
qataris du gaz donc il ya vraiment là
une négociation qui se fait à trois
bandes et l'idée je pense aussi de
recevoir le président français c'est
d'appuyer là où ça fait mal avec bien
sûr la faire des sous marins en asie
avec la vente annulée à l'australie où
depuis la france c'est très bien sur
quel pied danser face aux partenaires
américains qui s'est très bien avoir un
partenariat une amitié à géométrie
variable en fonction des intérêts des
états unis d'abord donc je pense que
c'est important de voir ça a presque
emmanuel macron a suffisamment de
pouvoir pour pouvoir imposer une vision
non alignés sur les intérêts de l'otan
et les intérêts américains c'est ce
qu'on va voir dans les jours qui
viennent aujourd'hui il se pose
évidemment parce qu'il est en campagne
donc ça permet de montrer qu'il est
président inter à la stature
internationale qui peut résoudre un
conflit est ce que c'est ce qui va se
passer ça je ne sais pas tout dépend en
réalité de joe biden qui aujourd'hui
rencontrer olaf scholz à la maison
blanche pour parler de bien autre chose
eric revel toujours bien pour un
président pas encore candidat mais enfin
candidat quand même de montrer qu'on
parle aux grands de ce monde qu'on
essaye de régler des des grands conflits
à 63 jours du scrutin on prend de la
hauteur c'est évident c'est évident
alors je ne dis pas que le président de
la république s'est déplacé juste dans
la perspective de sa future déclaration
comme candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais c'est sûr que ça
aide en terme d'image évidemment ça ça
impose une stature que les autres
candidats par définition ne peuvent pas
imposer puisqu'ici
sur sur les sur les intérêts moi j'ai
toujours en tête cette phrase de charles
de gaulle qui disait
les états n'ont pas d'amis n'ont que des
intérêts ça il faut l'avoir en tête
parce que quand on a l'impression d'être
bruges et sur un contrat d'avoir fait
confiance à des alliés historiques qui
finalement sont révélés c'est la petite
phrase si c'est ça mes amis je préfère
encore mes ennemis bon c'est de cette
phrase de charles de gaulle et emmanuel
macron me semble-t-il devrait la mûrir
parce que les états n'ont pas d'amis
n'ont que des intérêts et un chef de
l'état défend les intérêts de son pays
vladimir poutine
il peut pas admettre évidemment que
l'ukraine rentrer l'otan c'est comme si
si si la chine mettait une base
militaire au mexique j'imagine que les
américains réagiraient bizarrement
souvenez-vous de la crise des missiles à
cuba où les américains évidemment
n'avait pas tolérer d'avoir en face de
la floride des missiles qui pouvait
atteindre les états unis donc voilà je
pense qu'il faut l'avoir en tête cette
phrase parce que quelle que soit la
position qu'on adopte sur c'est ce
conflit potentiel en ukraine les chefs
d'états défendre les intérêts de leur
pays voilà ils peuvent s'apprécier ou
pas s'apprécier mais ça c'est autre
chose c'est bien autre chose mais je
crois encore et que c'est votre
candidate un autre jour sur le plateau
de nos confères de france 5 il a choisi
cet exemple 1 2 c'est comme si la chine
mettait des missiles au mexique valérie
pécresse qui s'est mis à part les russes
on va on va l'écouter
je veux dire aux fier peuple russe que
nous devons construire la paix en europe
et que commencer une guerre avec
l'ukraine serait une terrible erreur non
ça c'était la version française c'était
bien plus savoureux en russe si valérie
pécresse était aux affaires aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'elle ferait différemment
des manuels macron aujourd'hui là à
l'instant où on parle mon sentiment je
pense qu'elle serait partie plutôt dans
la discussion franche avec le président
russe comme vous rappeliez tout à
l'heure j'ai vécu moi 2008 et en 2008 il
ya une vraie différence avec aujourd'hui
au delà du fait que le président
français était en début de présidence
française de l'union européenne epa
enfin présidence française comme l'est
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron c'est qu'
aucun protagoniste aujourd'hui ne veut
la guerre alors qu'à l'époque la guerre
il était là et est vraiment le président
français de l'époque nicolas sarkozy a
arrêté la guerre je me rappelle très
bien de cette rencontre qui était sur la
même table autour de la même table mais
avec deux protagonistes au lieu d'un
pour que je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque
dimitri medvedev était président de la
russie et ben laden robin c'était son
premier ministre il venait juste d'être
président de la russie que quelques mots
avant et donc de ce fait là est arrivé
en invités entre nîmes et surprise bien
sûr vladimir poutine autour de la table
mais c'est vrai que le conflit était là
et le conflit était très fort là une
semence discussion un peu différente où
j'ai le sentiment que ni la russie ni
les autres protagonistes ne veuille la
guerre ne veuille le conflit donc c'est
plus une forme de théâtralisation
de montrer en fin de compte quel est le
plus fort et quels sont ceux qui veulent
d'une façon ou d'une autre bien limiter
leur territoire on est en fin de compte
dans une répartition
et ce soir ce sera sans doute le cas
dans les changes quel entre le président
français et le président russe s'est une
répartition de territoire on le voit
bien à quel endroit on s'arrête et à
quel endroit on estime que chacun a sa
zone et ça va être sans doute que la
difficulté de la conférence de presse
qui va suivre c'est en fin de compte il
faut pas qu'ils perdent entre personnes
perdre la face et donc de cette là on
peut arriver sur une décision un peu
molle pour reprendre la terminologie
d'une députée européenne c'est-à-dire
une définition qui sera pas très clair
parce que chacun veut sortir gagnant de
cette négociation et de cet échange
fabien les 17 de dramatisation dont
parle franck louvrier elle arrange
aujourd'hui le président pas encore
candidat ça a bon dos effectivement
d'une certaine manière ça sert les
intérêts des manuels macro qui a évoqué
cette crise ukrainienne en disant voilà
qu'il attendait avant de se déclarer
candidat
non mais c'est une situation extrêmement
complexe à laquelle emmanuel macron dois
faire face moi je m'étonne quand même
dans le discours trop longtemps qu'on
parle skin acceptable pour nos amis
russes au hockey autant discuter mars
j'entends que j'entends pas dessus le
riz par exemple si nous revoir des
missiles balistiques des russes sur
l'antenne de kaliningrad qui sont
pointés sur nos partenaires européens
par exemple son calme des listes y
balistiques avec des ogives nucléaires
voilà je vous rappelle que quand même
dans de basses en ukraine ce sont des
missiles anti char qui a réussi donc
alors on y pense pas que ce soit un
péril immédiate pour la russie donc de
faire depuis six ans parle de pays
souverains gira secondes de là la france
est tout à fait légitime à envahir à la
wallonie parce que avant c'était chez
nous les italiens sont tout à fait
légitimes à envahir les alpes-maritimes
parce qu'avant nice et la corse si
c'était chez nous une fois de plus
emmanuel macron divers dans le de faire
respecter aussi le droit international
donc tout on peut discuter avec la
russie sur le sentiment de sécurité
qu'elle a à ses frontières et quelles
sont ses zones d'influencé mais on peut
aussi discuter et l'intérêt des manuels
à l'écran c'est aussi de défendre les
intérêts de sécurité de l'union
européenne et le droit international
il s'était dans cette optique-là que
lemon way judas et certainement pas dans
une visée pour les physiciens parce que
il n'a peut-être plus à perdre si ça a
échoué qu'à y gagner donc je pense que
c'est courageux de sa part et une fois
de plus c'est là dit mercredi qu'il y a
invité parce que emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui l'homme sort de l'union
européenne il disait l'a71 rational
enfin je veux dire chaque analyste
chaque éditorialistes ont souligné en
fait le poids des manoirs en dedans dans
l'union européenne par rapport aux
initiatives militaires par rapport aux
initiatives diplomatiques enfin ceux qui
aiment la france est à porter
l'initiative européeenne d'intervention
c'est la france aujourd'hui qui avait
musclé ses budgets militaires nous
sommes tout à fait en cohérence avec la
place diplomatique que notre pays porte
à l'international et emmanuel macron
tout à fait crédit et qu est ce qu il a
à cet égard voilà donc deux jambes dans
la bouche de malades
lorsque viennent de nous des afghanes et
oui alors il ya évidemment de deux
façons de voir les choses et aussi la
façon de se dire qu'on est quand même
longtemps après la seconde guerre
mondiale et qu'il y encore quarante
mille soldats américains basés en
allemagne c'est peut-être anachronique
que le fait que les etats-unis soient
partout chez eux pour les opérations de
l'otan bien sûr les manoeuvres mais
aussi d'envoyer du matériel et des
troupes comme si ils avaient des
aéroports et des bases partout le plus
gros hôpital militaire américain en
dehors des états unis c'est en allemagne
toutes les opérations également qu'ils
ont eu lieu
au
moyen orient par ted allemagne donc il
ya un vrai problème aussi de
souveraineté réelle de ce côté gendarme
du monde qui aujourd'hui avec un monde
multipolaire et rendu beaucoup plus
difficile on a vu la débâcle en
afghanistan on a vu la débâcle en irak
des pays qui sont maintenant aux mains
des taliban pour l'afghanistan et dans
un dans un chaos dit délicat puisque
l'état islamique s'était installé là bas
il ya un vrai problème il faut quand il
faut comprendre aussi le côté pourquoi
est-ce possible pour un empire et
pourquoi finalement défendre sa
frontière pour la russie se serait vu
comme quelque chose de tout à fait
belliqueux et dangereux entre élites
mandaté du virus dans le dossier
craignant un jean paul garraud qui nous
a rejoint dans ce débat le député
européen du rassemblement national
bonsoir jean pierre garraud marine le
pen a souhaité faire sortir la france de
l'otan pour de plus je cite être
entraîné dans des conflits qui ne sont
pas les nôtres c'est ce qu'elle a dit en
substance samedi à reims au cours de son
meeting présidentiel c'est pour vous
l'un des enjeux de la présidence celle
de 2022
oui mais d'abord je voudrais dire que
emmanuel macron non pas du tout l'homme
fort de cette situation d'aucune façon
d'abord je les assume tout le monde je
pense il a remarqué emmanuel macron vous
voyez la disposition des lieux président
poutine le reçoit une table 4 mètres de
long à l'autre bout de la table et lui
serre pas la main il le fait rentrer au
kremlin par une zone très bien rodée
mais qui peut imaginer un général de
gaulle
une jacques chirac ou nicolas sarkozy
traité de cette façon là donc si vous
voulez ça veut dire simplement que le
président russe a très bien compris que
emmanuel macron il est d'un dans une
manoeuvre politicienne il va apparaître
comme celui qui va sauver la paix et de
ce côté là on arrive alors sur notre
sujet qui sont les risques réels les
risques réels de guerre donc par rapport
à la situation entre la russie et
l'ukraine il ya des spécialistes de la
question qui disent que effectivement
j'ai entendu aussi sur votre plateau que
personne ne veut la guerre dans cette
histoire je me souviens d'ailleurs de
très gars très peu de temps le vice
amiral
qui commande la marine allemande enfin
qui commandait le vice-amiral aux
chaumes bac il a dit c'est un
spécialiste il a dit non mais c'est une
ineptie le terme est une ineptie de
penser qu'il peut y avoir la guerre
entre l'ukraine et la russie alors il
l'a dit publiquement il a même dit
simplement que le président de tout
petit je voulais être respectée pourquoi
par rapport évidemment à ses zones
d'influencé par rapport évidemment au
fait que l'otan est de plus en plus
présente à ses frontières voilà c'est ça
son problème au président russe et le
vice amiral sund bac a été limogé parce
qu'il avait osé dire en réalité la
vérité non emmanuel macron ne pèse pas
grand chose de cette affaire tout ils
viennent de nous le montrer et c'est
triste et ça fait mal parce qu'à travers
le président français c'est bien sûr de
la france il s'agit mais la voix de la
france elle ne porte plus du tout dans
le concert des nations
dont on parle pas du tout depuis depuis
une dizaine de minutes c'est notamment
l'enjeu énergétique c'est que derrière
tout ça au chili il ya une forme de
rapport de force qui fait que nous
sommes dépendants nous sommes fortement
dépendant bien sûr de la production de
gaz et de d'autres
et les armes encore beaucoup plus et
c'est vrai que dans la dans la situation
diplomatique dans lequel on est on
oublie parfois ce volet qui est un volet
essentiel de la négociation et je dirais
du rapport de force du fait qu' il est
vrai le président russe en la matière
est plus puissant que l'europe entière
qui il est vrai est elle aussi considéré
comme pour les russes comme une forme de
protectorat américain et donc de cette
la négociation n'est pas à l'heure de 2
du moment en tout cas et donc qui il
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que le président russe préfère parler
directement avec le président macron
plutôt qu'avec des représentants
européens qui viendraient comme le
représentant italien pour représentant
de l'europe etc donc il ya là aussi je
pense à prendre en compte tout
l'environnement qui n'est pas uniquement
politique mais qui est aussi bien sûr
énergétique et qui fait que la tension
était forte parce que des deux côtés ça
met en cause aussi notre indépendance
énergétique de travail oui alors moi je
dirais de sur la question énergétique
est très importante mais il ya une
vieille tradition comme diplomate igolo
mitterrandienne un surmonte un peu dans
le passé parce qu'il ya des liens
historiques entre la russie la france
faut jamais l'oublier les il ya des
liens amicaux il ya des liens d'histoire
moi je me souviens avoir été à moscou
dans une petite chapelle où l'empereur
était venu parait-il s'y recueillir je
sais pas si c'est une légende urbaine
mais en tout cas ce lien historique
global entre la france et la russie fait
aussi je pense que la diplomatie
française qui était mise en place depuis
des années et des années
perdure cette tradition diplomatique
goulot mitterrandienne en fait emmanuel
macron l'incarnent et le fait qu'ils
soient président du conseil européen est
présent la république française pour les
russes je pense que ça veut dire aussi
autre chose que si un président du
conseil italien ou ou si un premier
ministre britannique on se demande ce
qui viendra faire là d'ailleurs demandé
ou avait un tel entretien c'est pas la
même chose la relation franco russe
allait quand même historiquement très
forte jean pierre garand vous disiez
voilà un outil d'accueil à votre opinion
en tout cas
emmanuel macron avec voilà pas le
respect qu il se doit en substance enfin
voilà ce que vous disiez m'enfin il y
disait hier quand même c'est un
partenaire intéressant
on mettra le temps qu'il faudra pour se
parler vous l'avez entendu également
président poutine mais quand même
certaines formes par ailleurs et c'est
bien normal le président poutine je
pense qu'il ne supporte pas trop les
sanctions qui ont déjà été prises contre
lui et contre surtout contre la russie
et il ne comprend pas peut-être enfin
oui le comprend peut-être trop
finalement
cette position qui est celle de l'union
européenne et celle de la france parce
que la france est et là dessus une
meneuse en quelque sorte à l'encontre de
la russie moi c'est quelque chose qui me
dépasse il voulait la russie la russie
la france comme cela vient d'être dit la
russie la france ont une histoire
commune on a on est en fait très proche
en fait nous avons une civilisation qui
est évidemment très proche souvenez-vous
de gaulle bien sûr qu'il disait que
l'europe s'était de l'atlantique à
l'oural voilà or la position on fait de
la russie quelque chose enfin un pays
qui est quasiment pas un ennemi ce sera
un mot trop fort mais qui est
véritablement rejeté de notre part et
c'est évidemment tout à fait anormal le
président français lui a été en dessous
de tout malheureusement au niveau
international au mali nous avons perdu
53 soldats et au mali malheureusement
le gouvernement actuel nous a congédié
quasiment et on n'a rien fait le
président maquereau a pris note si vous
voulez les sous marins australiens 56
milliards donc d'euros nous échappe avec
la vexation où la france n'a pu ça doit
alors évidemment le président
le soutien des manuels seront ce fait on
fait bien l'airé qu'est ce que vous
répondez à jean pierre jean paul garraud
non je pense que l'on matière diplomatie
la caricature est la pire des choses
j'admire heures quand on parle que le
président poutine au sort bout d'une
table de 8 mètres de long le présent la
république en fait si la plaisanterie de
ceux qu'on accuse les images il a reçu
tout ce temps le clipper internationaux
de la même façon vas-y un footing pour
des raisons sanitaires y compris votre
ami viktor orban figaro donc arrêtez de
dire n'importe quoi sur internet
politique
vous mélangez avec le mali bon on
sapphire c'est pas du tout la même
histoire tragi repas de ce s arrête au
les caricatures ont dissuadé attaque
sérieuse alors je sais très bien que
vous n'êtes pas pour une europe l'union
européenne fédérale se prend un haut
niveau qui thomas tic au niveau
militaire mais c'est l'agenda du
président de la république française je
pense qu'il a été clair devant le
parlement européen donc nous assumons
parfaitement cet âge là et des français
dans deux mois il y aura des élections
et des français transformante donc voyez
on dit dans un champ tout à fait
démocratique et une salle de plus c'est
quand même la russie aux ordis et moi
j'aime beaucoup la russie dont je dis
très tranquillement mais qui ne respecte
pas le droit international et dont vous
n'écoutez bonne raison pour pas
respecter le droit international
je pense qu'ils sont reprendre le
dialogue un dialogue rationnel
raisonnable mais ferme avait là aussi
alors monsieur gare aux cheveux roux
roddick/n ce qu'a dit le président
poutine tuer nos interlocuteurs de
qualité je t'attends nous prendrons le
temps d'un défaut prend des choses ce
qui se fait parce qu'on est sur l
entretien très longtemps si c'était pas
un interlocuteur de qualité
penseriez
a répondu caricature
on avait vraiment je crois qu'il ya une
chose qu'il faut bien comprendre dans le
tempo du moment c'est que le présent
poutine c'est son quatrième présidence
française qu'il vaut face de lui qu'il y
a un passif notamment due à monsieur
lors de monsieur macron par exemple sur
l'annulation des commandes des bpc mais
énormément marqué le président russe qui
avait été choqué par cette annulation et
à l'époque monsieur macron était
secrétaire général adjoint de l'élysée
et je pense que monsieur poutine est
bien informé de cette histoire et est
donc de ce plat il ya tout ce passif là
qu'il faut aussi un moment donné prendre
en compte parce que lui il en a vu
quelques-uns président français et donc
tous passif la haie et et est un élément
aussi sans doute difficile dans la
négociation merci en tout cas tous les
quatre ont un petit peu en retard
vous exprimer mais ça sera pour la
prochaine fois merci fabien lainé merci
beaucoup alexis paulin et franck
louvrier